[Music]
i'm astronaut nicole
mann i'm astronaut frank lubio i'm nasa
astronaut
jessica meer
uh so there's about a million things
going through my mind as i think about
going to the moon
you know the little kid inside of me
just got super excited for me that has
always been this dream mission
this driving exploration and curiosity
of that next step
you know just the excitement the amount
of effort and the teamwork that goes
into such an amazing
expedition and really what it means to
humanity so it's very exciting
if i can be a part of those missions in
any capacity it will truly be a dream
come true
i think it is important that in 2024
we're going to see the first woman walk
on the moon and the next man
and it is a huge team effort but what it
does it just shows the diversity that we
have
in nasa in the united states really in
the world
that the barriers are broken down i
think
for all of us that are involved on this
artemis team we would all be absolutely
thrilled to be the first woman on the
moon
and to know that even if it's not me
that i probably know the first woman
that's going to set foot on the moon
is something that is so fulfilling
so it really wasn't until a little bit
later on in life that i realized that i
wanted to be an astronaut
you know as a young woman i was
interested in math and science
but i didn't realize maybe the
possibilities that were out there
my mom says i first started saying i
wanted to be an astronaut when i was
five years old
everybody associated that with me all
through my childhood
my dream was always to be a physician
and to be an army doctor and then to be
a special forces
doctor and so i was kind of living my
dream and i was in my dream job
and then a friend recommended that i try
out for the program so it was really
very
late i think for me it was really a
combination of things
of having this fascination for science
and nature and the world around me
the fact that i can continue to be part
of something that's bigger than myself
there's so many things out there you
should never limit yourself the
possibilities
are absolutely endless
i think he's pretty excited i think you
know he's a little worried about
me leaving home for an extended period
of time i think
he's only eight so i think as any
eight-year-old kid would be
but i think he's also very excited and i
tell you it's different now
sometimes we always sit outside and we
love to look at the stars and look at
the moon
but now i think both of us look at it
with a little different
um light in our eyes and a little
different twinkle
knowing that you know someday soon we're
going to be
you know back there on the moon and
hopefully someday he'll be able to watch
mom um fly by and walk on the moon
when we do hard things and we challenge
ourselves as humanity
to take on big challenges it brings us
together
and it pushes us to develop new
technologies
new ideas i think exploring space is so
important
really for the benefit of all of
humanity
this is just an innate characteristic in
the human species to explore
science and technology development to
exploration
of our species as humans and
and where we're going and where we came
from understanding
more about our solar system about our
universe about the formation
not only of other planetary objects like
the moon and mars but of our own
and you also see the benefits back on
earth from science
development and also just inspiring the
next generation
we end up changing our lives forever and
i think for the most part
uh for the betterment of mankind when
you look back at the planet from above
you don't see any of those man-made
geopolitical boundaries that we've
imposed upon ourselves
and it's so easy to realize how we truly
are
all in this together we are all one
[Music]
you